[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
care less and you know what it is you
know why we here oh man first I like to
give a shout out desire not as you I
could tell I'm still getting over my
cold right so um I like to give a shout
out to Zion art design art is fan art
custom statue maker distributor it's a
one-man band well it's a group but when
I tell you you know they do it all from
concept to design to painting to
distribution they are one of the premier
custom statue guys that you can ever
deal with when I talk about rapid
shipping that comes all the way from
China
I'm talking about a degree of care with
packing for communication customer
service is top-notch
the level of detail on the custom
statues I've received three custom
statues from Zion Ark and I believe that
they are at the forefront of custom
statues every statue that I received
from them has an unparalleled level of
care unparalleled level of detail it
rivals some of the best I'm talking
about is pushing against XM definitely
sideshow and prime one studios so when
you purchase from Zion art you can
purchase with a level of confidence that
all the way through the process you will
be informed you will see progress and
when shipping tracking to delivery
they are always phone click away so
without further ado I would like to give
you Sian arts one for custom Loki on
throne
when I first saw the Statue posted I
quickly hit them up you can follow them
on Instagram which will be the easiest
way to reach out to them and I
automatically hit him up I said yo
listen um I need that statue uh what's
going almost Apiata so hope I didn't
miss and I was able to get in on the
pre-order I got in on the pre-order of
the god du monde throne I got in on the
pre-order of the Hulk man both statues
did I previously received from them
more tremendous this statue behind me is
godly it captures exactly the the
depiction of the concept just fully
because you got to understand when it
goes from a concept of a 2d picture the
artists must take that TD picture and
make it a 3d reality now some people
complained that he wasn't using all of
the chair he's playing chess he's deep
in thought as a mystical chess board
where he's leaning in interacting with
the pieces while touching his hair
this Loki on throne captures the god of
mischief in a perfect light we all know
the story of Loki he's basically a
spoils of war
Odin went and tried to conquer the frost
giants and in doing so he basically
stole a baton now
Loki was basically cast aside because he
was a small frost giant he wasn't a
large frost giant but being that he's a
shapeshifter he was able to look like a
child and he was raised as an Asgardian
Loki is supposed to be the polar
opposite of Thor
Thor's tall beautiful strong long blond
hair but dumb is a break
loke it's not supposed to be as handsome
dark hair not as big but smart as anyone
in Asgard somebody found out that he was
a son of a frost giant of course there's
a level of animosity that he had towards
Odin that he always felt that Thor was
his chosen and rightfully something
[Music]
there goes that level of hey there goes
why the motivation of Loki is key
there's also the reason why in the first
Avengers movie the first Avengers comic
book Loki is the villain Loki brings The
Avengers together just like the movie
[Music]
the ideas it takes a god to be the god
Thor comes in but it took all of their
efforts this Loki on thumb is probably
one of the centerpieces of my room as we
speak the candlesticks are strong and
epic the base the steps leading up to
his throne looks like concrete the floor
looks like concrete the rocks on the
side with the frost on it looks like
rocks and frost his throne is made out
of wood covered by a sheet of ice you
can't really tell by the pictures but
the ice shimmers and as you go down to
the base you can tell that is its wood
down at the base of the throne gasps his
jacket laid to the side before his cloak
his fur collar his fur boots his iconic
green and yellow the leather straps his
horns
I cannot understate the level of detail
that went into this meticulously done
statute we're not even getting to the
[Music]
chessboard which is a feat within itself
360 degrees of pure detail the chess
board pillar is more detailed than half
the statues that you will receive from
other companies the board lights up not
a cheapy little light I'm talking about
it illuminates in the dark a bright
light
[Music]
it comes with um four crows they have to
be put down at the base of the pillar it
came in so many pieces and I had to put
it together if there's one not one
negative it should come with some form
of instructions on how to put it
together first because it is not as easy
as it seems you lay it out and it takes
a degree of certainty and engineering
basically to put this statue together
without breaking anything this should
come with some extra pieces because I'm
gonna tell you you're gonna break a
finger or so on on those little hands
there's little bone hands that's holding
the chess board separate the pieces are
greatly done the chess pieces are
individually moulded real chess pieces
the board illuminates green the chess
pieces can be manipulated and put in any
order any place you want the
illumination rises up on his face this
statue is one of the peaks this is a
Holy Grail everybody looks for Grails
you know for some some some might say oh
I don't like this or I don't like that
it could have came with some double-a
batteries because double-a batteries
powers the light of them the chess board
kind of came with that it did but if
those tools the only negatives that you
can take away from this statute then you
are in rarified air I highly recommend
you sit watch the video at the end to
see the statue in all its glory
I took tons of pictures
more video this statue warrants your
time and your attention this
is one of the best statues that I have
and I can't stress it enough
Zion art is a reputable company to do
business with
I've heard of terrible deals that went
down with other companies and other
Commission's every time I've ordered
from them it's been top-notch around the
ball this is the part of the video where
I'm going to ask you to like follow and
subscribe and also hit that join button
because we going to pax baby
we're media we hear taxes our home also
goes and Lords of gaming got net when
you can get other episodes of Carol West
I urge you to go look at design art dude
god du monde throne I urge you to go
look at the hawkman DC's Hoffman was a
huge statue epic earns you to go look at
those old videos also look at combat
talk with the king
heart gaming reviews with Lord addict
and also the last word with loyal
kognito and avanti's we have tons of
opinion pieces there tons of fat pizzas
and a lot of speculation in the industry
we have PlayStation 5 coming out
we have Xbox series X ever ton of
information and there's a wealth of
knowledge there for you so trust me
there's something on that website for
each and every last one of you and also
go to our teespring store we can get
some of our merch you can get that epic
throw them in the bushes or who done
that for you one would be there for you
it's it's a good time so stick around so
you can see this incredible statue in
all its glory
again Zion rc1 full custom and our loki
enthroned not to be messed with trust
it's a Holy Grail
[Music]
Oh see you next week say I'm so amped up
right now see you next week while I
bring you a statute that's near and dear
to my heart and something I had to have
always stay collected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]